ausziehen verboten wenn Eltern dich
zurückhalten da bin ich jetzt im Wiener
Wohnung und ich bin ja
Seiten aber erst mit 26 und da hast du
jetzt Nicole
irgendwie schon krass erst mit 26
auszuziehen also für mich persönlich
jetzt ich bin mit 16 zu Hause ausgezogen
und bin so froh so früh eigenständig zu
sein mit 26 war ich dann schon
verheiratet und hatte Kinder ja hey ich
glaube viele reagieren so für mich ist
natürlich einerseits von der Kultur her
schwierig sie zum Vorstellen früher
ausziehen und auf der anderen Seite bin
ich im Vergangenheit gesehen also ich
habe einfach mega Spaß gemacht
sie und auch von der Ruhe wenn wir
alleine ist da und letzte Jahre habe ich
mega oft über das Thema schwarz mit
meiner Kolleginnen und irgendwie auch
nicht gemerkt kann es gab Filmen
depressiv könnte werden oder ja die
ganze Zeit traurig ist und ich habe
einfach gemerkt
der Kommentar gefunden
da schreibt er interessant wie viele
Kommentare das lange bei den Eltern
bleiben pauschal als schlecht
verurteilen und den frühen Auszug als
grundsätzlich gut anschauen
und gleichzeitig davon ausgehen dass nur
die Porträtierten Familien von Kultur
und Tradition geprägt sind
und da fragt jetzt der Wagen soziale
Druck ist ist das nicht auch der soziale
Druck welcher einem bewegt auszuziehen
jeder bei der Arbeit fragt nach wann du
eigentlich ausziehen willst bei den
anderen Kulturen schaut man oft was
andere denken und lässt sie nicht
ausziehen hey das beschrieben war
wirklich das was ich erlaubt haben weil
bei der Arbeit hat immer sind die Fragen
immer so hey warum
bist du
bist doch Journalistin da ist mir doch
selbstständig und irgendwie hat
er hat wie eine zu überleiten dass ich
vielleicht nur andere
Glück wird wenn wir früher aussieht und
ich merke einfach
und schlussendlich muss entscheiden
dann steht der Duft Notiz was auffällt
niemand kann den genauen Grund nennen
warum die Kinder so lange zu Hause
bleiben die Antworten sind halt einfach
es ist normal es war schon immer so wir
können es nicht anders es ist unsere
Kultur das sind halt leider keine
richtigen Gründe und es ist nicht sehr
zeitgemäß
das ist nicht so zeitgemäß ist das
verstand ich
aber es braucht natürlich auch Zeit ich
meine ich bin jetzt aus der zweite
Generation
von der tamilischen Diaspora und ich
habe einfach gesagt es passiert viel ist
der zweite Generation mehr hinterfragt
sich
älter gemacht hat macht Sinn dass ich
das genauso mache ist das vielleicht
anders
bricht und ich glaube es braucht einfach
lügt wo
ausprobieren und den Lügen willst dann
ist und dann tut mir halt einfach einen
neuen Norm bestimmt
und uviel hat sich halt gemolken
Andreas schrieb
bin sekundo und mit 24 Geburtstag meine
älteren
belangt ich glaube der Perserteppich
muss ich mir mitgehängt
so gut vorstellen
wir plötzlich danach die Unterstützung
kommt weil das bei mir genau gleich
gehabt
und
ja Luther Sachen und und
da steht love trees krass ich bin mit 15
weg von zu Hause weil die Lehrstelle
weit weg war ich kann nur noch am
Wochenende nach Hause nach der Lehre
sollte ich wieder zu Hause einziehen ich
war aber schon abgenommen meine Mutter
hat sich auch schon von mir gelöst ich
schwer pubertär wir haben nur noch
stritten es war für uns beide eher Zwang
noch einmal zusammen zu leben deshalb
wurde ich mit 18 gebeten auszuziehen
ich war damals noch nicht bereit
auszuziehen mit 21 wurde aber von meinem
Vater dazu ermuntert ich bin dann später
noch mal zurück zu meiner Mutter gezogen
bis ich mit meinem Studium fertig war
der zweite ausziehversuch hat dann super
geklappt und ich fühle mich seither auch
sehr wohl in der eigenen Wohnung hey
gratuliere ich finde auch wenn du zum
zweiten Mal musst zu den älter wieder
Wunsch finde das überhaupt nicht schlimm
weil ich finde es mega menschlich wenn
du bei mir versuchst es klappt nicht für
mich nicht
wohl allein sie dann goferit
Gang noch mal hi und dann
probier es noch mal
dann haben wir dort du hast geschrieben
ich bin 24 Jahre alt möchte bald
ausziehen und fürchte mich jetzt schon
vor dem Gespräch mit meinem Vater solche
Situationen sind wirklich kompliziert
ich meine man selbst ist in einem
anderen Land aufgewachsen in einer
anderen Zeit und einige haben dann die
Erwartung dass man sich genauso wie aus
der damaligen Zeit in der entsprechenden
Kultur benimmt hey ich finde es unschön
hast Du da geschrieben und vor zwei
Jahren habe ich am Tag genau die gleiche
Gefühl kann also ich habe
mega respektakel mein Vater
konfrontieren und sagen
und sicher irgendwie beruhigend dass mir
nicht dass man mit einer Gefühl nicht
es ist einfach so du bist nicht allein
du bist nicht die einzig wo so Gedanken
hat und ja
ich das Gefühl
bei mir hat es mega cool für das jetzt
Mini
ältere hinter mir gestanden sind und
es ist es ist einfach zum fühlt sich
einfach wirklich gestützt wenn ältere
einem unterstützend ich bin mir aber
bewusst dass es wird älterer genauso ein
großer Schritt ist zum Kind loslassen
und dann schrieb nur wegen Verhalten von
der Ältere ich danke eltern sollten sich
fragen warum sie solche Schwierigkeiten
haben mit dem Auszug der Kinder oft sind
es egoistische Gründe nicht allein sein
wollen besitze greifen das Verhalten
verletzter Stolz und so weiter
beobachtet dass es einfach darum geht
dass die ältere egoistisch sind
was ich gemerkt habe
dass es auch um Angst kommt
[Musik]
mit ihren Gefühlen
und zum Schluss noch ich Genüsse das sie
aber ich bin auch nichts auf mega froh
wenn ich wieder bei der Ältere darf sie
also ich schätze mega dass ich meine
ältere immer wieder der Suche und ich
kann zum Teil auch wenn
im Umfeld New Yorker Stunde und
natürlich ich nehme das als und sage hey
ich komme wieder heim
aber ich finde das gar nicht so schlimm
dass mir ab und zu mal wieder zu den
Eltern und auf jeden Fall sage ich euch
erste Firma für viele Kommentar und dass
sie die Reparatur getanzt das schätzt
sich total und wenn ihr mir so etwas
wünscht dann abonniere doch der Kanal